welcome to this video play tarnish
Massenet with that shake this both Nick
Nicola both Nick huh okay
I have zero why was this I know I'm
losing a bit of time David I have zero
or three in one minute okay okay yeah I
played the occasional one minute game
but not often
okay that did cost a bit of time okay I
can also go here okay the classical
Queen's Gambit early c6 that's usually
good news normally white is keeping
slight edge in this type of position
okay nothing in particular
b5 that's really passive they normally
play b6 in this structure and okay to
get the the bishop possibly traded with
Bishop a6 but that's not not on anymore
and that's kind of the dream position of
this opening and you have a excellent
space advantage like has very little to
show for it Wow
really g4 you're not just getting killed
there is a bit messy but okay that must
be good forward
I mean I'm not a huge fan of combining
before and g4 in any kind of situation
but I think it should just be good here
right okay look at this
OTC don't look f8 No so even g5 is in
okay Knight takes what does this move
then threatening on e6 and Bishop h7
Wow what a disaster
how do i how to have win now that looks
nice
Queen over to h2 would be great so
probably here and you cannot really move
they have six Knight f4 Queen edge - and
made on h8 that's the the way you want
to do it yeah okay
I mean rook h8 wins the Queen I actually
saw that but I didn't want to I thought
there must be more let's still go for
for Queen h2 that just just just looks
looks too strong actually to not play it
Queen edge to Queen edge admit how is he
preventing that okay Queen h2 and don't
see a defense Queen h8 mate
just made maybe you can disparado
something here like this Jack Bishop g6
I guess but let's think for a moment
it's okay I'm threatening Queen edge a
check
Knight g8 takes on g8 King takes Bishop
f7 king of Uruk h8 mate this happens
after Roxy three
okay it's not happening I can still
check him there yeah I'm just I'm just
tons of material up here and after that
yes to give the Queen check Wow okay
check
still queen h8 I mean this I'm insisting
on that black forfeits due to
disconnection hmm
okay don't really know why why not just
resign okay I was just a disaster of the
game yeah I mean I think around here
this is this is quite a comfortable
position in any case but night aged 5
and then f5 is really really a bit a bit
much I mean after g4 I'm basically
winning the problem is I mean I think
the best move is actually night back to
a6 and give give the f5 pawn which is
really terrible to look at but I think
he has to do that he teaches and and
after that it's just it's just toast
what is the comp giving just for fun +5
okay and here we are here we are maybe
in mate territory Bishop e5 is actually
the best move yes yeah okay Bishop g6 is
made in five okay I okay
Bishop f7 mate yeah that's strong
actually yeah of course yeah that's very
strong and now rook h7 estimating move
very neat check
checkmate okay that was in quicker but I
don't believe that is a safe for him no
that's plus 15 2017 h2 plus 7/2 plus 27
okay that's just a question of time when
the calm seas are made check cheeks
Bishop here takes their kick Queen h8 it
doesn't matter it's just fun to look at
check this this wins the Queen check
chairman nothing I mean okay one check
this is mate mate I actually actually
saw that made check because that that
motif was was in earlier okay once that
was nice okay well thanks for watching